why do we study history history is the
stories of thousands of years of men and
women who have lived and all those years
all that experience is what we are
studying in history there is so much
wisdom to be gained from it so we have
you know we're lucky 80 years here on
this earth and over that time we can be
in quite a bit of experience we could
become wiser by the year but if good
student of history is going to benefit
from the from the mistakes and you know
and then and there in the right actions
of men throughout all of human history
and secondly history is it's vital
because we are we're studying our
heritage we need to know where we came
from we live in a great country where'd
it come from what are the good things
that it has to offer it and had how did
they get passed down to us first and
foremost history has done through
stories we tell stories in class we read
about stories we read about these great
men throughout throughout throughout the
ages we look at pictures of
civilizations how people used to live
who these men used to look like dressed
like we memorize or maybe even sing
songs about them or we recite poems
ballads which are honoring these great
men so some some initial thoughts for
how a parent can support their child's
history instruction after they come home
so first thing I will talk about is ask
them about what they're learning good
history instruction includes many many
questions so first find out who are you
studying about today who are you
studying about right now why are you
studying this person what noteworthy
thing did they do
Oh to crisis were they dealing with or
what good did they have to offer what
decisions this man make when he was in
that crisis or in this difficult
situation was it the right decision if
it was right why was that the right
decision for this time and by this man
was this man just was he good was he
wise why do you think he was wise why do
you think he was foolish these sorts of
questions will force a child not only to
reengage that material but he's gonna
make it more of his own because when you
have to explain a thing you
truly come to understand it second
thought read with your child history
teacher is assigned a good bit of
reading there from a little biographical
stories or the textbook some textbooks
can be a little more more difficult to
get through but the the stories are
still there still a narrative being
shared and oftentimes if you read these
things aloud it'll become a much more
pleasant for the child to learn from it
and doesn't have to be things that are
strictly in the curriculum ask your
teacher for other resources maybe your
child is really taken in to athenian
athenians living in greece so ask for
supplementary resources other
biographies have men from that time and
then read those with them you could also
read stories from read them these
historical stories before they go to bed
if they are after all stories and it
doesn't need to be treated as this this
boring subject which belongs only in the
school place this is a thing which
should be done at home as well
so third off you are history
your your parents your grandparents
every family has a long history however
much of it you do know share that with
them around the dinner table talk about
where they came from where you used to
live what times used to be like not so
long ago because for them ten years ago
is a very long time ago they don't know
anything about it and for those who
perhaps more know more about the other
time ancestry.com right now has a free
14-day trial or you can go look up who
your ancestors were where they came from
if that history has been lost to you for
thought documentaries this might be
better suited for older groups but
documentaries include lots of pictures
lots of videos so I think even some
younger students can can enjoy watching
these with their parents find things
which are supplemental to what they're
studying right now so they can bring
some extra knowledge into the classroom
next time they go in there and there's
so so very much out there Amazon and
Netflix have countless documentaries and
they keep producing more because people
want to know history they want to know
where they came from who these people
that they once studied were libraries
also have a lot to offer
you can melcat bring a variety
items and there's so much out there I
can only really recommend trial and
error to find out what's good there are
some Ken Burns for instance who's always
going to produce quality documentaries
but there are many others out there that
I have not tested and I can't say for
sure just give him a try the first two
episodes are boring as tears move on to
something else and v projects projects
are a great way to bring that history
from the classroom into into the home
teachers in classical schools don't
spend a lot of time on projects that's
not because they're inherently bad but
you can you can take something from a
history class let's say you were
studying ancient Rome and at home say
well let's build a Colosseum right it's
a fairly simple structure on the outside
you buy styrofoam you glue the pieces
together you maybe even paint it if your
student is artistically inclined and you
have a little model Colosseum in the
house for those who are who who like
drawing or coloring drawing a soldier
one of my history projects from my 6th
graders was always control or Roman
legionary and I told them which weapons
he had to have the color of his garments
and the students would either find a
version online trace it out for those
who weren't as capable and then color it
in other students would try draw it you
know you know freehand you see what they
could come up with and they they really
enjoyed that some bits of it's a it's a
great practical application of history
if that's very practical at all chopping
wood with an X this is in some sense
living history at least for most men
throughout all of human history if you
have an axe and you trust your child to
wield it take the young you should show
that you I can bring you buy some wood
or maybe just go find some wood find a
tree chop it down split it into pieces
and then make a fire that is that is
every man's experience throughout our
humans humanity's existence even to this
day and this last one might be arising
suspicions but memorize a speech I say
this because students might not think
they want to memorize a speech but when
I was in seventh grade and desirous of
being a quiet one sitting in the back
corner I was forced to memorize a speech
no I chose Genghis Khan as the man I
wrote a fake speech for him and then
I delivered it in front of my classmates
and when I got to take on the ethos of
this individual and put words in his
mouth about the things that he
accomplished and the terrible things he
did it was pg-rated it was it was a it
was a great moment for me and surprising
amounts of fun I'm still wasn't signing
up to give speeches here and there but
it was it was quite a wonderful thing so
history at home ask them what they
learned read with them tell them your
story watch documentaries and and find
little projects to do and you'll bring
that history to life in the home